foreign
bigotry was
rapidly disappearing from the landscape
um to the point that when Jeremy Lee
Quinn and I were talking on our program
remind our audience
freelance journalist who has been in all
of the hot spots including January 60 so
Lefty uh Anarchist but anyway a very
good journalist
was there on January 6th actually went
into the Capitol and observed it
firsthand
um anyway interesting guy and he was
describing I think he was actually
describing January 6 to me when I
interviewed him and and uh he told me
with some excitement that he had
actually met a racist like a guy was
just admitting it and talking about yeah
he didn't dig other races and all of
this and I was excited too because
neither of us had ever met one of these
people in the wild right they're very
rare like and was he in a cage or did he
get to touch him right it was remarkable
he even had a sign you could just find
him in the crowd based on his sign I'm a
racist pretty much something to that
effect yeah and so you know there is
something a little bit I don't know
quaint about that that it's somebody who
is so off the living dodo bird right
he's a he's a living dodo
um but anyway so they are rare but then
you can hear the Pearl clutching and
fainting couch reaching and all of the
stuff that people do because of course
they know from personal experience just
how much of this stuff is out there no
you don't what what is out there still
in large quantities is ignorance
absolutely which is not the same thing
as bigotry yep right so anyway we've
been making that distinction for a long
time there's lots of ignorance you and I
have plenty of ignorance too as does
everybody else but I'm not saying that
I'm there's nothing to the accusation
that I'm a racist but yeah I've got
ignorance and you know I didn't grow up
in anybody else's home I didn't grow up
in anyone else's culture it's simply
that but then you make the next point
which is actually though racism is
common it's just back that's what it is
it's a new kind it's some sort of Neo
bigotry
right and uh I think that's the sticking
point is that now the racists look very
different from what they once did you
know it's not that retro dude at the
January 6th protest uh it's some kind of
new racism where the focuses are
different but nonetheless it's
um you know this obsession with race
right which D individuates people and
exposes people to you know again it's
you know it doesn't matter that you
think you're doing it because you want
to be good the point is no you're
separating us by race again and you're
taking away the thing that's key to
Being Human and substituting something
you know grotesque that does you know
not superficial superficial official and
there's no way it could possibly work
hmm
so actually I did have a uh a thought
about how to deal again I had a few but
I thought this one was good we'll see
um so the idea is how do you deal with
these new racists right and so what I
was thinking is um
you
you just carry around with you for the
moment that you need it um some Saltines
in a little package and then when you
encounter uh one of these white folks
that is now newly obsessed with race you
just uh cracker
my feeling is that that would be it's at
least a conversation starter you at
least might get a few gaskets blown they
might blow a gasket right exactly no
they could start I don't know where we
have our gaskets actually
human gaskets yeah oh uh the blood brain
barrier I think that oh that's that's
probably it that is the one that's
probably it so so
covered by the cause some gasket blowing
a little a little gasket blowing yeah
yeah and some haphazard repairs all
right so you were you also wanted to go
somewhere else uh the shoe on the other
foot thing yeah so
for
since we ended up in the public eye as a
result of the unfortunate thing that
happened at Evergreen to me and then to
us
people have come to me regularly and
they have basically said I'm in a
terrible situation it's happening to me
what should I do
and it is clear that when somebody comes
to me they pretty much want to hear me
say okay here's how you stand up to that
and I'm very reluctant to do this right
especially if it's not someone you know
right and you don't know anything about
all of their circumstances
right because what I know is that you
and I landed on our feet and we landed
on our feet for lots of different
reasons we had
a good support network we did lose a
bunch of friends but there was enough
there to escape the implosion of
Evergreen and to make our way in the
world in a different in a different
manner
I don't know that for anybody else right
and if somebody stands up to the Mob
because it's the right thing to do and
they lose their job and their family is
imperiled or worse because of that
catastrophe then I don't want to be the
one to say yeah it's cool to stand up to
the Mob because as much as I think it's
important that we stand up to mobs
it's not all you know look
if we hadn't landed on our feet
we at least have family
right we have family and
it would have protected our children
not everybody's in that spot so anyway
I've been very reluctant to give the
advice that I know people want me to
give and other heterodox folks have
often confronted me over this like why
won't you tell them what they want to
hear we need people to stand up that's
how we're going to defeat it they're
coming to you you know what they want to
hear right and I agree we do need them
to stand up but I still it's my moral
responsibility not to give somebody
advice that would be good for me but
potentially bad for them in their
situation right so anyway I have
failed to deliver the advice that I know
is probably for the global best because
it is interpersonally not fair to expose
somebody to them
but this is the situation that you have
found yourself in here where somebody
that you care very much about was taken
as a hostage by a mob that had some
power to do harm and I see you going
through exactly the
um
the various machinations over
um you know the responsibility of oh my
God I put this person in in Peril right
and it I will feel terrible if this by
knowing that there are two Sexes animals
right by doing your job right right
um but yes no and I and I and I said to
them at some point sort of in the middle
of this like I
I don't think this is what
you're thinking of doing I don't think
you want to do it I don't think this is
what you want to hear from me
this is mostly about me relieving
pressure on myself
you know you I need you to know
that it's okay if you know if you
disavow me like if yeah and I
you know they didn't of course they
wouldn't normally they wouldn't yeah
they wouldn't it was never a possibility
but I just felt such
it's not it's no longer just about me
and like this this is so fundamentally
The Human Condition yeah right and I
didn't I didn't see this coming exactly
because
we went through this together and so I
felt I had I knew and you know we had
students and there was like there were
effects on students and like we were
navigating all of that in real time
I just I I didn't see this coming where
I felt both responsible to while knowing
that I was in no way responsible for
yeah the situation right responsible to
the person
making sure that they wouldn't feel
that they didn't feel obligated to a
sense to me to do something that was
going to imperil
lots of things
um while also knowing as did they as as
everyone who can see this with any
Clarity like I'm not responsible for
this thing this is about the bigoted mob
on the other side
wielding power
yep
um with some
wiggle room over individual cases where
somebody truly has extreme Jeopardy yeah
I'm now seeing the situation differently
because I'm watching you make the
arguments that I would make and I'm
watching you feel the responsibility
that I would feel and I feel very
differently from the outside
um and I think the key thing is a we
know how this Dynamic works it's not
like the first time anybody's seen this
kind of mob we've seen this mob hundreds
of times right in many different
contexts it's always the same right you
apologize to it does it get placated no
quite the opposite give them an inch
right they take it off second thing is
it is a
contagious game theoretic object
right its purpose is to get you to back
down so that it will move on to the next
person and the point is by backing down
you fueled it so in one sense you know
you've got a person who is confronted
with an unfortunate mob right that
person is in Peril and the instinct is
oh my goodness to the extent that I'm
responsible for you being confronted by
a mob I feel absolutely obligated to do
everything I can to get you out from in
front of that mod however
if you do that
the mob comes for somebody else right
and so and destroys all the good things
right along the way and so in some sense
we're dealing you know it's it's 2023
right this happened to us in 2017 we did
stand strong and we demonstrated how
that could be done and we were lucky to
be in a position where we were
comparatively uh well situated to do it
but
we needed more people to do it in order
that it wouldn't still be going on in
2023 yeah and so in some sense I'm now
looking back at the people who I was
reluctant to say no actually you really
do have to stand up people who as you
point out came to me because that's what
they wanted to hear and given that they
came to me and that's what they wanted
to hear I probably should have said it
oh interesting
that's what I think okay
[Music]